if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do it
[Music]
dumps
big massive dumps
[Music]
dumps dumps dumps
dumps
[Music]
dump big massive dumpsters
times that it was massive dumps that led
him to lose the election which is just
dumps dumps
[Music]
[Music]
tremendous amounts of water where the
water rushes out to sea
[Music]
dump big massive dumpsters
[Music]
[Music]
the election
what is going on here
what is going what is going on here
convalescent plasma it's just beyond
parody massive dumps cost them the
election
[Music]
cents okay
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't mangoes like
three boxes
that's it
eight or 11 bucks
[Music]
bring my mango back down
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identified from the
mangoes
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
all right welcome everybody what a major
day it is almost to the day the one year
anniversary of joe biden's
becoming the president of the united
states president as some say defendant
and he will be holding his first formal
press conference in months now the
right-wing media
all of a sudden formal press conferences
are a really big deal if it's been a
couple of months since you held one
it's the topic on fox news for weeks
and he's doing it today okay so i'm
expecting a number of different nasty
questions to be asked and
that's coming up at the top of the hour
so i think that that's a really
great thing now i do want to warn people
it is so windy outside the studio i hope
we are not knocked offline
the entire studio could end up up in the
air
based on what's going on sir your wife
is up in the air yeah the studio could
end up flying through the air and i hope
that that doesn't happen but i'm just uh
warning everybody in advance because
there is just so much going on okay
i do have a new audio element in the
sound board this is from the trump rally
on saturday and we will ban men
uh it was like really weird the context
is that trump said we will ban men and
people cheered and then he added from
women's sports but the pause was very
strange and it almost was like he was
confused by what it was even on the
teleprompter so that's my new one and we
will ban men
exactly and i noticed that i've been
under using
my own alex jones impression remember
this one globalist internationalist
trotskyite socialist shun like obama
trudeau macron
and the rest of these zio beasts
right i don't understand why every
right-wing conspiracy theorist has that
weird sean connery thing and i was
watching a video of roger stone today
complaining about ron desantis
tell me if you think i may be onto
something that sh is caused by them
getting fake teeth that are too big
because ivanka has that shush
don jr has it they both seem to have
gotten the fake teeth a little bit too
big
roger stone has a clearly fake mouth
full of teeth
so i think that it's
they i think it's it's what it is
because they didn't if you look at old
videos of ivanka she didn't used to have
that
um
anyway just something i've been thinking
about devoting some time to
uh i don't understand why they why they
all have it globalist internationalist
trotskyite socialist shun like obama
trudeau macron and the rest of these zio
beasts
and we will ban men okay
all right let's uh let's move on and
continue we are in the middle of a
brutal
hype train on twitch and i want to say
thank you to
sweet thang
ucc mart tina thiru
and a danish joint for the twitch
subscriptions putting us in right at
four
for the day
i do have a bunch of people who are
demanding they be unbanned on twitch
let's adjudicate these i still have my
gavel
but you'll notice that it is broken and
look at this
it's crumbling
because of the force with which i've
been adjudicating these requests
it's now like a short throw shifter
almost
it's it's literally crumbling under the
weight of the unban requests
so i will uh i'll continue using it
until it's just
sand left essentially but it is getting
to the to the end because we've been
strike and strike hold on do i have that
commander
okay i don't have
i don't have the exact thing okay let's
take a look here um
here's a user named drew the dog man
who showed up to my chat
and said
um
you're a grifter quit lying
okay
um the vaccine is experimental in the
fact that you can't show me any face
three studies oh they met phase three
no face three studies that have been
completed
and then david are you still gaslighting
people about the border crisis they were
banned
and then their unban request was just
the word gay
so that is a deny
and it is a perma-ban
that's too easy
another user showed up named little
ofc
ppc
and said trump is right
david pakman is cringe they were then
banned
their unban request is you really ban me
because i said trump is right you
already know you cringy
uh it's very incoherent and idiotic and
bad faith so that is a perma
a lot of perma today
um poker villain showed up
and said we need to worry about tyranny
australia is tyranny new york city is a
hell hole
does david think the russians stole the
election
i wish the vaccines worked
i missed kaylee
uh they were banned
and then they are they're unbanned
requested i didn't say anything will
i'll will just humor
that's a perma-ban it's too stupid
uh wow a lot of these
someone showed up a few days ago and
said trump won 2020 they were banned for
spreading disinformation their unbanned
message is they stopped counting votes
on election night these are wildly
debunked lies and it is a permaban
all perma today
and then user the doctor disgrace
um
oh my god this is toxic
uh there will never be a fair election
since social media why do liberals like
unemployment
then they said it was a joke i'm sorry
please unban i watch cnn every day we
are part of the same cult i just say
republican stuff to get a reaction unban
me please war with ukraine is good
because we need to invade them if russia
invades them unbanned please we have
same views i was almost like okay i will
unban but that is such a toxic and
erratic unban request that it's gonna be
a perma
okay and by the way one of those people
was a paid subscriber you think i won't
you think you can pay your way into
being toxic on my streams
you can but not at two bucks a month
okay uh no i don't care guys even if you
guys are
if you're toxic you're getting banned
if you're toxic you're getting banned
that is it watch how much i care about
uh banning
paid subscribers get the hell out of
here
get off my stream
okay very good
all right let's look at some super chats
here david direction do you predict the
us would go in with a republican
majority senate and white house a
dystopian authoritarian direction
noah says david you broke your mic when
you hit it oh i hope that's not true
jody says apparently botox can cause
weird lispy stuff oh interesting
maybe it's not the fake teeth but it's
the botox that's that's interesting
okay very good
so okay we've done that let me see what
else we have uh we've got about 20
minutes until this is scheduled to start
here's a voicemail i got with an
interesting restaurant related question
hey david do you think lon jon silvers
is a front
i do i do i don't know what it's a front
for but i i am i do think long john
silvers is a front now um
what is longjohn silvers is it like red
lobster
is it like fast food seafood let's take
a look at what long john silvers is
um
they're definitely fronting but i don't
know for what
so let's see oh they mac and cheese huh
menu let's see what's what it's all
about
uh so it seems like it is sort of
seafood
about our seafood they've got wild
alaskan pollock is it all fried or no
okay shrimp salmon chicken is under
seafood that's weird
is chicken considered seafood now
that's a good question actually
um
hmm
they love alaska oh my god they have the
oh my cod
c meals wow i've never i've never even
been near one of these places sort of
interesting
oof that salmon looks very odd to me
i've never had salmon this color
maybe it's supposed to look that way i
don't know
clams
huh well
let's look at one other section maybe um
variety platters oh no let's look at the
grilled menu
grilled salmon grilled shrimp variety
grilled shrimp and salmon grilled salmon
bowl
grilled shrimp shrimp bowl grilled
salmon tacos tac i know someone calls
them tacos you guys ever heard that
and grilled shrimp tacos
okay well there it is i do think long
john silvers is a front but i don't know
uh yeah it's no bubba gump exactly well
said well said i don't know what it's a
front for but i do feel strongly that
it's probably a front
okay
so that is that
let me uh so we did the voicemail
uh very good i do want to say thank you
to quantum goob light chaser and jen
here for the twitch prime subscriptions
i also want to implore you implore you
start the year off right
january is the best time to get a
membership on my website joinpakman.com
coupon code obama
and you will get a huge discount and i
will thank you
on stream
and everybody will feel really really
good about it okay let's see what else
i've got a few different clips i wanted
to go over with you guys this is so i
don't i i think maybe you guys have the
react the uh explanation our friend
dylan burns recently did an in-person
debate
somewhere does anybody know where or who
he was even debating like i have no clue
this is just crazy but i don't know
anything about it does anybody know who
dylan debated and where
nobody knows dallas texas infrared
dallas texas debating infrared has
man i don't is infrared the name of the
of the place or the name of this person
that's the person
infrared has
uh
who who the hell is that
he doesn't even have a thousand
followers on instagram what do you mean
who is this
it's a lefty tanky
it was for debate khan
okay anyway
our friend dylan burns was debating
someone and the guy seemed to have lost
his mind look at this
hold on a second
and the independence movement of taiwan
has never been popular it's always been
a marginal phenomena a phenomenon we can
infer was definitely propped up by the
americans chiang kai-shek himself had to
uh butt head a few moments
you look like a fat
[Music]
[Applause]
he said dylan looks inbred fat what does
that even mean
[Music]
this was left on left debate like this
is just crazy it's super edgy yeah i
know i know it's very very edgy
um
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god is that what the revolutionary
left is now they they call people the r
word and they they just that's horrible
guys again i have no clue who that is
i'm taking your word that it's a
revolutionary leftist but it's just like
what what is this you know i've been
getting invited to so many in-person
things lately stuff like this
and i'm just thinking to myself
i've got the studio so i can produce my
best quality show here i'm gonna take
time off to go a lot of this stuff they
don't even pay you they're like we'll
pay for airfare it's like okay
uh take three days off
to go to something where someone's gonna
you know say i'm inbred fat or whatever
i mean it's it's just crazy it's crazy
i've been turning all of it down the one
that i did get invited to that i want to
do once things are a little bit calmer
is uh patrick bet david invited me he
said he wanted to interview a
progressive
that's a progressive folks remember
and um that i do want to do because he
has a huge platform he has like 4
million youtube subscribers they just
want me to fly down to florida right now
and i'm not
quite ready to go back to florida after
the recent covet scares
but at some point i do want to do that i
think that that would be uh that would
be very very much worth it
jake says david pacmanica should be
added to adam sandler's chanukah song
sure
sir checking in from andalucia my
temporary home glad i could catch a live
stream yeah i've never been there i've
been to many parts of spain
but never uh never andalusia
thanks to p satan and dimmy bob for the
twitch prime subscriptions very much
appreciate that very very much
appreciate that
uh okay so that's the dylan burns thing
let me see if there's other
so what was the guy's name hazma no wait
what what was it infra
infra dylan burns let's see if there's
other videos from it it seems no
or was it infra has
dylan burns and i talk of gun no i don't
even know apparent infrared oh okay
infrared
[Music]
is there even an audience here or are
they just in a conference room alone
also why is it that no matter the angle
this guy's face is covered by that
camera
also why is their camera so close
where really will i be quiet on bottom
of what
me because i'm talking this is the
debate it's conversation okay okay don't
don't sit here you will be quiet don't
be quiet i'm not gonna [ __ ] be quiet
yeah so also like is it necessary to put
them right below the
exit sign like could we possibly come up
with a worse shot
so they both talk at the same time all
right so that's that let me just make
sure we're not missing anything here no
all still good um okay this is really
funny the new thing
that's going around is um these
right-wing tick-tockers or they're
they're they they're they're on
tick-tocks as you many of you know
they go to grocery stores and they point
out that there's like no food
and i'll be honest the other day i went
to a grocery store and there were a
bunch of different things that were
missing
and some some of the things that i was
surprised to see missing like for
example um
for my salmon pesto orzo i couldn't find
orzo at one grocery store i had to go to
a different grocery store to get orzo
now could i have used israeli couscous
yeah yeah
could i have used rotini
sure
sure
but i went and found orzo elsewhere
that's rare you know that's i didn't
find that okay so anyway here's some
tick-tocker and the things she says
they're out of you can clearly see on
the shelves so it's not it's not having
the right effect i don't think take a
look at this
hey guys i'm currently shopping at h-e-b
okay what's heb does anybody know what
heb is
i've never heard of that i don't know
what part of the country that's in
texas it's a texas grocery grocery store
okay
texas grocer good let's continue
by the way
texas which is run by republicans
why why aren't they to blame for empty
shelves why is it joe biden in dc to
blame for empty shelves in texas
i don't know
okay
just finished going to church and i've
never of course she went straight from
church fairy got it got to squeeze that
in
never seen these shelves so empty so i'm
going to show you because this is what
biden's america is happening isn't this
greg abbott's texas
i don't know
even in small towns in texas look at
this there's no milk just
so that looks like it's the like the
fast like the the candy milk isn't it
doesn't that look like it's the fat like
the chocolate and sugar milk some
chocolate milk over there oh there's no
chocolate milk and we come up yeah look
here
it's it's exploding with milk you guys
see this right it's it's there couldn't
be more milk there's like three little
things here this might even be some
other type of milk from the packaging
it's full of milk
there's almost too much milk here they
need people to come and buy it
okay we're here
i've never seen an empty milk shell now
let me back it up a second hold on
there's no milk just some chocolate milk
over there
and we come over here
i've never seen empty milk shelves
look at how that's full orange juice
shelves okay now
the orange juice shelves
do look pretty sparse
to be totally frank when i look here
this does not look
you some of you i'm going to lose some
of you here i know
this doesn't look like
normal orange juice this looks like the
orange juice drinks
that are just riddled with sugar
like it doesn't this doesn't actu
because often when where i find the or i
don't even drink orange juice
but when i rarely get it i'm not getting
it from the refrigerated section where
it's like the drinks i'm just getting it
from where it's like it's stored on the
it's shelf stable because it's not been
opened yet these look like
sugar-riddled
juice elements we're better off out of
those
okay let's continue
this is biden's america right here empty
shelves and i it sucks to see this is i
would argue this is communism
yeah like
look at these shelves
empty
empty i've never seen this ever in my
life until today and i'm shocked hey
guys
oh man
it's just like okay you know i i get it
i get it
uh but there's there's global supply
chain issues exposed by the uh by the
pandemic
um
okay
let's see what else we've got here
uh oh this is this is pretty
entertaining a mexican tv host lost it
on anti-vaxxers and started calling the
morons i like this this is in spanish
but let's take a listen anyways
[Music]
um
so he's saying that the anti-vaxx people
are imbeciles he used the word imbeciles
twice
and he said at minimum put us put a mask
on if you're not gonna get vaccinated
[Music]
[Music]
okay
so uh man that is the best that that i
like that
um and then we're gonna be covering this
very strongly on today oh let me see if
i'm so okay so this is it is about to
start um i covered this on the podcast
today which if you were a website member
you would already have access to because
we publish it six hours before for
everybody else okay um now they wanna
nebulize hydrogen peroxide
extraordinarily dangerous
um oh hold on i have a couple of david
if we become a dictatorship in 2024 will
you flee the country yes if the u.s
becomes a bonafide dictatorship in 24
i'm gone
very much so and matt from providence
says hey david thoughts on mmt and have
you read stephanie kelton's book the
deficit myth can you give me an obama
obama um yes i have many videos on mmt
i've interviewed stephanie kelton
multiple times so extensive public
record of my views on that
uh okay let's take a look at this uh
nebulizing
hydrogen peroxide stuff don't do this
this is dangerous
uh there's been a lot of articles saying
oh this is terrible for you don't ever
do this yes it's extremely dangerous
ever uh inhale uh nebulized
hydroperoxide but
uh if a doctor is going to go on and
actually say to do this
uh you know i trust in the one doctor
again i forget his name but i'll post
the videos
he trusts the one doctor whose name he
forgot over every other doctor saying
don't do this
mercola has a conversation mercola's a
lunatic
never ever ever uh hold on a second
let me tell you about dr mercola
oh man
one of the most uh
hold on a second here
one of the most effective
show you this guy
disseminators of disinformation
um
let me see if i can get to
here we go
uh actually do we even really want to do
this right now
anyway read about mercola read about
mercola it's it it's just bad i'm not
even gonna get into it now let's
continue i'm with them
um in uh
rumble i think they're also on bed shoot
right really talk [ __ ] shoot
um if you want if you need medical
advice
ignore every doctor other than mercola
whose videos you can find on rumble and
[ __ ] huet
what
about the guy's been doing this since
the 90s now he also utilizes uh
uh iodine um puts like also debunked
we've already talked about it iodine
into the into the medicine bottle here
i haven't tried that yet i'm going to
try it uh i'm actually got someone order
and see
the iodine that they're recommending i
think it's
it costs like nine bucks for two little
bottles or something like that so
again there are different ways to do it
but i find that this is the easiest way
plus you got it like you know in the
fridge and it's ready to go so whenever
i go to a rally or i'm going to a
restaurant or i went to the movies the
other night and stuff like that
and you know i don't ever wear a mask so
uh not that they help but that's
actually a brilliant part of it right
there where he goes you know
because when i go out i don't wear a
mask i nebulize this stuff
not that the masks work so it's like
he's saying because i'm not taking this
precaution i'm unprotected
even though that also doesn't really
protect me but still because i'm not
masking i'm doing the nebulizing of
hydrogen peroxide wait a second if it
does how why does it matter if you're
not doing it if it doesn't actually do
anything for you
i the first thing i do is i come in and
i put one of these on
also
i don't have to wait for that to be
honest with you uh when i get up in the
morning i do this
and since then i haven't been taking uh
any antihistamines
uh anything like that i haven't been
taking uh any cold medication i haven't
had any like why would you take cold
medication so think about how weird this
is
it's like
he says one of the great things about
nebulizing hydrogen peroxide is i've
stopped taking antihistamines and cold
medicine
why were you taking that stuff before do
you have a cold like what
what does that even mean i don't i no
longer am taking those things who what
congestion
um my sleep has been a lot better
um i i i and i attributed to this
because it's the only thing that i've
done
right
this is the only thing he's now doing so
it must be because of this um you know
always be on the uh uh be on the def be
you should have a red alert going off
when someone tells you that one thing
can treat or or or mitigate
so many different things right he's like
i'm nebulizing
iodine and hydrogen peroxide i'm
sleeping well i'm not congested i'm off
antihistamines i'm off cold medicine
it's like what hold on a second what
what what cures this much stuff
different so
um nebulizer 80 bucks 90 with tax look
at that uh i would say eight to ten
dollars for for the food grade 12
hydrogen peroxide his voice actually
sounds terrible i don't know what his
normal voice is but it's not sounding
great to me outside for 100 bucks i
think it's it's worth it and again like
i said i
i went to the movies the other night in
pasadena you don't have to show a vax
card and we didn't wear masks and uh
we're in the
you know in there with a bunch of you
know backstop people shedding all over
us and everything like that that's the
other thing which is this will protect
you not only from covid but also from
vaccinated people which they believe
they need to be protected from it's too
good it's too too too good
this should be in some kind of time
capsule along with uh along with this
and we will ban men
yeah that even though they got math
going i put you know the first thing i
did as soon as i got home as i uh hit
this takes about 10 minutes to to go to
the end here
and oh my god 10 minutes of nebulizing
these things watch tv while you're doing
it it's not that obtrusive it's a little
loud but it's not that loud it's loud
that's also funny
and uh man these guys are willing to try
anything
other than the vaccine like they'll take
anything you give them just they'll take
it iodine nebulize hydrogen peroxide
urine therapy they'll drink the urine
they'll rub it all over themselves what
about the vaccine which is actually
approved for this now oh my god no no no
no that's crazy
that's crazy can't do that
um
and for people saying if you think this
is not check out homeopathic medicine oh
believe me i know and i know there's
many people in my audience who get mad
at me
guys i'm just reporting the science on
homeopathic medicine which is um
it doesn't have any active ingredients
that's that's just it it's that's it i
don't there's it's not medicine
i don't know how else to explain it to
people
i want to say a huge thing as i lose
half the stream i want to say thank you
to eric goodhue
for signing up on my website with the
coupon code obama
and his new member number 10
thank you thank you thank you thank you
i would love it
if you grabbed a membership on my
website today joinedpakman.com
we primarily depend on that as a source
of revenue as many of you know we've had
facebook revenue go to zero
we've had tvich revenue go to xero
we've had youtube revenue go to zero
we've had amazon revenue go to zero
but our website revenue
has no middle person
and that's why it's so important and you
can use the coupon code obama for a
discount also we are counting patreon
pledges double today
chef tragon
just made a pledge on patreon and that
counts as number eleven
and number twelve
okay i very very much appreciate that
um
if you think this is nuts someone
recommended bleach yes exactly
apply
light and heat to
cure
and then i see the disinfectant is there
a way we can do something like that
by
injection insulin we hit the body with a
tremendous uh
very powerful light supposing you
brought the light inside the body
right
exactly convalescent plasma very very
important stuff
there um okay
all right so we took care of that
um
yeah i do have some voicemails i've
fallen way way behind oh thanks to
kangawanga for the twitch prime
subscription i do appreciate that
let's listen to a few voicemails yeah
let's do it we have them here
uh let's see eric from mass checking in
with another one of his uh predictions
so far he's owe for a million
hey david it's ever from math the uh
virus is in the vaccine it is not
actually the mrna vaccines do not
contain the virus that's why um
everyone in the hospital is vaccinated
the unvaccinated uh just
sitting there wondering why they keep
going to the hospital why the vaccine
they keep passing it to each other
omicron is running right through you
guys
so everything eric is saying there is
untrue
i want to say thank you to crystal his
second domestic press conference since
take dear god uh i want to say thanks to
christopher mcinnis for signing up on my
website with the coupon code obama
that's new member number 14 today we
should do a new coupon code soon with
banned men and we will ban men that
would be we'll do that soon we'll do
that soon other voicemails there i have
so many voicemails uh whitney checking
in
okay what i don't understand is
how come
people are like
like
half black and half white oh when they
have one black parent and one white
parent they are half black and half
white that's an ease i'm glad whitney
got a substantive question that i was
able to uh answer directly
hey david
i was just curious um how much elite and
homosexuality do you have um
i understand theater has a lot i know
jane cooper has a lot
i was just curious about you how much
blatant homosexuality do you have
um all right thanks
that's really really dumb
um
let's see what else we're not even gonna
not even gonna entertain that it's so
stupid
let's see
um
oh here is joe biden uh joseph r biden
jr and here is the president good
afternoon everyone
tomorrow will mark uh
one year since i took office yes it's
been a year of challenges but it's also
been a year of enormous progress
we went from two million people being
vaccinated at the moment i was sworn in
to 210 million americans being fully
vaccinated today
we created six million new jobs
more jobs in one year than any time
before
unemployment dropped the unemployment
rate dropped to 3.9 percent
child poverty dropped by nearly 40
percent the biggest drop ever in
american history
new business applications grew by 30
percent
the biggest increase ever
and for the first time in a long time
this country's working people actually
got a raise all right let's see if we
can get better audio elsewhere these
working people
actually got a raise
actually got a raise people the four the
bottom 40 percent saw their income go up
the most of all the caterers
we cut health insurance premiums for
millions of american families and we
just made surprise medical bills illegal
in this country
you know those bills you get that you
don't expect after two to five thousand
dollars from the hospital beyond what
you thought you were going to have to
owe because the consultation you weren't
told was going to cost that much right
no more
they're now illegal
thanks to the american rescue plan and
other actions we've taken
we've seen record job creation record
economic growth in the past year
now
thanks to the bipartisan infrastructure
bill we're about to make a record
investment in rebuilding america to take
us to be the number one
what best infrastructure in the world
well now we're way below that
we'll be creating better jobs for
millions of people modernizing our roads
our bridges our highways our ports our
airports
everything from
making clean water let removing lead
pipes
that every american turnout every
american can turn on a faucet and drink
clean water
urban and rural and suburban communities
it's going to make affordable high-speed
internet available to every american in
urban rural and suburban areas we've
never done that before
now we are we're in the process of
getting that done
still for all this progress i know
there's a lot of frustration
and fatigue in this country
and we know why
covert 19.
omicron has has now been challenging us
in a way that uh it's the new enemy
but while it's caused
for concern
it's not cause for panic
we've been doing everything we can
learning and adapting as fast as we can
and preparing for a future beyond the
pandemic
all i know that after almost two years
of physical emotional and psychological
weight of this pandemic and has the
impact it's had on everyone for many of
us it's been too much to bear
we're in a very different place now
though
we have the tools
vaccines boosters
masks test pills
to save lives and keep businesses and
schools open
75
of adults are fully vaccinated
we've gone from 90 million adults yeah
sorry guys i do hear that drone in the
background let's see if this is better
we're adding about nine million more
vaccinations each week
we're going to stick with our
vaccination efforts because vaccinations
work
so get vaccinated please
and get your booster
look we're also increasing testing
should we have done more testing earlier
yes
but we're doing more now we've gone from
zero at home test a year ago to 375
million tests on the market in just this
month
if you buy a test of the store your
insurance will reimburse you
on top of that
we're making 1 billion 1 billion at home
tests available for you to order and be
delivered to your home for free
just visit covettest.gov
i got mine know how to get that free
test kit to your home in addition there
are 20 000 sites where you can get
tested in person for free now
and now
we have more treatments that people can
that for people who keep people out of
the hospital
than any other point in the pandemic
including life-saving antiviral pills
we purchased 20 million of these new
pfizer pills more than any country in
the world
and the bottom line on cover 19
is that we're in a better place than
we've been and have been thus far
clearly better than a year ago
we're not going to back
we're not going back to lockdowns wow
we're not going back to closing schools
schools should stay open
because the american rescue plan
we provided the states 130 billion
dollars 130 billion dollars to keep our
students and educators safe and schools
open
funding for ventilation systems in
schools social distances hygiene for
classrooms and school buses
in addition we've added another 10
billion dollars for covet 19 tests to be
able to be ministers administered at
schools
and many states and school districts
have spent this money very well
unfortunately some haven't
i encourage the states and school
districts that use the funding to
protect our children and keep our
schools open use it
the covet 19 is not going to give up and
accept things uh you know it's just it's
not going to go away immediately but i'm
not going to give up and accept things
as they are now
some people may call what's happening
now the new normal
i call it a job not yet finished
it will get better
we're moving toward a time in covet 19
and won't disrupt our daily lives
recover 19 won't be a crisis
but something to protect against and a
threat
we're not there yet but we will get
there
now the second challenge we're facing
are prices
covet 19 has created a lot of economic
complications yes including
rapid price increases across the world
economy
people see it at the gas pumps the
grocery stores and elsewhere
so here's what we're going to do
a critical job in making sure that the
elevated prices don't become entrenched
rests with the federal reserve
which has a dual mandate
full employment and stable prices
the federal reserve provided
extraordinary support during the crisis
for the previous year and a half
given the strength of our economy
and the pace of recent price increases
it's appropriate as the federal chairman
chairman powell the fed chairman powell
has indicated to recalibrate the support
that is now necessary
i respect the fred the fed's
independence and i've nominated five
superb individuals to serve on the
federal board of governors
men and women from a variety of
ideological perspectives
they're eminently qualified
historically diverse and have heard
bipartisan praise
i call the united states senate to
confirm them without any further delay
and here at the white house
and for my friends in congress the best
thing to tackle high prices
is a more productive economy
with greater capacity to deliver goods
and services to the american people
and a growing economy where folks have
more choices
and more small businesses compete and
where more goods can get to market
faster and cheaper
i've laid out a three-part plan to do
just that
first
fix the supply chain
covet 19 has had a global impact on the
economy when a factory shuts down in one
part of the world shipments to shops and
homes and businesses all over the world
are disrupted
covet 19 has compounded that many times
over
a couple of months ago in this very room
we talked we heard dire warnings about
how the supply chain problems could
create a real crisis around the holidays
so we acted
we brought together business and labor
and that much predicted crisis did not
occur
99 of the packages were delivered on
time
and shells were stocked
and notwithstanding the recent storms
that have impacted many parts of our
country
the share of goods in stock at stores is
89
now
which is barely changed from the 91
before the pandemic
i often see empty shells being shown on
television 89
are full which is only a few points
below what it was before the pandemic
but our work's not done
my infrastructure law
will supercharge your effort upgrading
everything from roads and bridges
to ports and airports
railways and transit to make the economy
move faster and reduce prices for
families
second thing
my buildback better plan will address
the biggest cost of working families
face every day
no other plan will do more to lower the
cost for american families
it cuts the cost of for child care
many families including the people
sitting in this room if they have
children and they're working a lot of
people getting banned guys 14 000 a year
for child care in big cities less than
that and smaller ones
my plan cuts that in half
that will not only be a game changer for
so many families budgets but it will
mean so much
for the nearly two million women who
women who've left the workforce during
the pandemic because of things like
child care
my buildback better plan cuts the price
of prescription drugs so insulin
that today costs some people as much as
a thousand dollars a month
will cost no more than 35 dollars a
month
it cuts the cost of elder care it lowers
energy cost and it will do all this
without raising a single penny in taxes
on people making under four hundred
thousand dollars a year or
raising the deficit
in fact my plan cuts the deficit
and it boosts the economy by getting
more people into the workforce
that's why 17 nobel prize winners for
economics
say will ease long-term inflationary
pressure
the bottom line
if price increases are what you're
worried about
the best answer is my build back better
plan
third thing we're going to do promote
competition
look in too many industries a handful of
giant companies dominate the market in
sectors like meat processing railroad
shipping and other areas
this isn't a new issue
it's not been the reason we've had high
inflation today it's not the only reason
it's been happening for a decade
but over time it has reduced competition
squeezed out small businesses and
farmers ranchers and increased the price
for consumers
we end up with an industry like the meat
processing industry
where four big companies dominate the
markets
pay ranchers less for their cattle they
grow
charge consumers more for beef hamburger
meat whatever they're buying prices are
up
look
i'm a capitalist
but capitalism without competition is
not capitalism right it's exploitation
so i signed an executive order to tackle
unfair competition on our economy and
we're going to continue to enforce it
along with working with congress where
we can
a close of this we have faced some of
the biggest challenges that we've ever
faced in this country
these past few years
challenges to our public health
challenges to our economy
but we're getting through it
and not only are we getting through it
we're laying the foundation for future
where america wins the 21st century
by creating jobs at a record pace
now we need to get inflation under
control
we have developed an extraordinarily
effective booster shots and anti-viral
pills now we need to finish the job to
get covert 19 under control
i've long said
it's never been a good bet to bet
against the american people or america
i believe that more than ever today
we've seen the grit determination in the
american people this past year
but the best days of this country are
still ahead of us not behind us
i'm happy to take questions get
vaccinated
yes
thank you mr president i know some of my
colleagues will get into some specific
issues but i wanted to zoom out on your
first year in office
inflation okay let's go here where we
can see that zoom out on your first year
in office
inflation is up
uh your signature domestic legislation
is stalled in congress in a few hours
from now the senate uh an effort in the
senate to deal with voting rights and
voting
voting reform legislation is going to
fail
covet 19 is still taking the lives of
1500 americans every day
and the nation's divisions are just as
raw as they were a year ago did you over
promise to the american public what you
could achieve in your first year in
office and how do you plan to course
correct going forward
why are you such an optimist
look
i didn't over promise
and but i have probably uh
outperformed what anybody thought would
happen
the fact of the matter is that uh
we're in a situation where uh
we have made enormous progress you
mentioned the number of deaths from
covet well it was uh
three times that not long ago it's
coming down everything's changing
it's getting better
look um
[Music]
was it ever 4 800 a day i don't remember
that take a look at what we've been able
to do
uh you'd have to acknowledge we made
enormous progress but one of the things
that i think
is something that uh
one thing i haven't been able to do so
far
is get my republican friends to
get in the game of making things better
in this country for example i was
reading the other day and i had i wrote
the quote down so i don't misquote him
a quote from senator sununu when he
decided that
excuse me governor sununu when he
decided he wasn't going to run for the
senate in new hampshire here's what he
said
they were all for the most quote they
were all for the most part content with
the speed at which they weren't doing
anything
it was very clear that we just had to
hold the line for two years okay
so i'm just going to
be a roadblock for the next two years
that's not what i do sununu said
he went on to say it bothered me
that they were okay with that
then he goes on to say i said okay so
we're not going to get stuff done
if we win the white house back
if we win the white house back
why didn't we do anything in 2017 and
2018.
and then he said how the republican
sununu spoke to answer the challenge he
said crickets yeah crickets
they had no answer
i did not anticipate that there'd be
such a
stalwart effort to make sure that the
most important thing was that president
biden didn't get anything done then
that's a big miscalculation because it
was pretty damn obvious
what are they for
they mean one thing they're for that's
true so that's true the problem here is
that i think what happens what i have to
do
in the in the change in
tactic if you will
i have to make clear to the american
people
what we are for we passed a lot
we passed a lot of things that people
don't even understand what's all that's
in it understandably remember when we
passed the affordable care act
and everybody thought that you know it
really was getting pummeled and beaten
and it wasn't until after out of office
and that next campaign when uh that
off-year campaign
and i went into a whole i wasn't in
office anymore in a whole bunch of
districts campaigning for democrats and
republican districts said they wanted to
do away with with uh health care with
obamacare
and i started pointing out that if you
did that pre-existing conditions would
no longer be covered
and they said huh
we didn't know that we didn't know that
and guess what
we won over 38 seats
because we explained to the people
exactly what
in fact had passed
now one of the things that i remember
saying and i'll end this i remember
saying to
president obama when he passed the
affordable care act i said you ought to
take a victory lap
and he said there's so many things going
on we don't have time to take a victory
lap
as a consequence no one knew what the
detail of the legislation was they don't
know a lot of the detail of what we pass
so the difference is
i'm going to be out on the road a lot
making the case around the country
with my colleagues who are up for
re-election and others making the case
of what we did do
and what we want to do
what we need to do
and so i don't think i've over promised
at all and i'm gonna stay on this track
you know one of the things that
i remember and i'll end this
i was talking with uh you know uh
jim clyburn
right who was a
great help to me in the campaign in
south carolina
and jim said and when he would endorse
me and there was a there was a clip on
television in the last couple days
of jim
and it said that we want to make things
accessible and affordable
for all americans
that's health care
that's education
that's
prescription drugs
that's making sure you have access
access to all the things that everybody
else has we can afford to do that we can
we can't afford not to do it
so i tell my republican friends here i
come
this is going to be about what are you
for
what are you for
and lay out what we're for
um uh
mary bruce abc thank you mr president
you mentioned your republican colleagues
but right now your top two legislative
priorities your social spending package
and voting rights legislation are
stalled blocked by your own party after
months of negotiation you are only
guaranteed control of washington for one
more year before the midterms do you
need to be more realistic and scale down
these priorities in order to get
something passed
no
i don't think so when you say more
realistic i think it's extremely
realistic to say to people these are
such fraught questions like
the it's it's
that you this question is asked every
it's just it's a meaningless question
spend a lot of time which i'm glad you
do pulling this data determining where
they are what the american people's
attitudes are etcetera
american people overwhelmingly
agree with me on prescription drugs they
overwhelmingly agree with me on the cost
of education they overwhelmingly agree
with me on early education they
overwhelm and go on the list on
on child care
and so
we just have to make the case what we're
for and what the other team's not for
look
we knew all along that a lot of this was
going to be an uphill fight
and one of the ways to do this is to
make sure we make the contrast as clear
as we can
and one of the things that i think is
we're going to have to do
is just make the case i don't think
there's anything unrealistic about what
we're asking i'm not trying to i'm not
asking for castles in the sky i'm asking
for practical things the american people
have been asking for for a long time
a long time
and i think we can get it done
you're not going to scale down any of
these priorities but so far that
strategy isn't working you haven't been
able to get some of these big
legislative ticket items done real big
wins down bigger than any president has
ever gotten in the first year but
currently mr president
your spending package voting rights
legislation they're not going anywhere
we mean between months 13 and 14. you
can get signed into law before the
midterm elections yes i'm confident we
can get uh
pieces big chunks of the buildback
better law signed in law
and i'm confident that we can take the
case to the american people that the
people they should be voting for who are
going to oversee whether elections in
fact are legit or not should not be
those who are being put up by the
republicans to determine to determine
that they're going to be able to change
the outcome of the election so i have to
tell you i find the questions and the
answers pedantic and almost meaningless
what's going on on on the uh um on
voting rights and the john lewis bill
and others but uh um so
look this is
i i've been engaged a long time in
public policy
and i don't know many things that have
been done
in
one fell swoop
um and so i think the bet the most
important thing to do
is try to
inform not educate inform the public
of what's at stake
in stark terms and let them make
judgments and let them know who's for
them and who's to get them who's there
and who's not there and make that the
case and that's what i'm going to be
spending my time doing in this off-year
election
you mentioned republicans in reaching
out to them some republicans who may be
open to major changes on voting rights
for instance like mitt romney he says he
never even received a phone call from
this white house why not
i like
look mitt romney's a straight guy he's
uh that's true
one of the things that we're doing i was
trying to make sure we got everybody on
the same page
in my party on this score and i didn't
call many republicans uh at all
the fact is that um
i do think that mitt is a serious guy i
think we can get things done i think
there's some reality to being like
listen if i need 10 republicans
assuming i have all the democrats and i
don't even have all the democrats it's
kind of pointless to call mitt romney
right i mean come on give me give me
give me a sense of the math here the
case why it's so important
to not turn
the electoral process over to political
persons who were set up deliberately to
change the outcome of elections
um
the uh uh
allison harris please
thank you thank you mr president
speaking of voting rights legislation if
this isn't passed do you still believe
the upcoming election will be fairly
conducted and its results will be
legitimate
well it all depends on
whether or not
we're able to
make
the case to the american people that
some of this is being set up to try to
alter the outcome of the election
and it's one thing look
maybe i'm just
being
too much of an optimist remember how we
thought not that many people were going
to show up to vote in the middle of a
pandemic
we had the highest voter turnout in the
history of the united states of america
well
i think if in fact
no matter how hard they make it for
minorities to vote
i think you're going to see them willing
to stand in line
and and defy the attempt to keep them
from being able to vote i think you're
going to see the people we're trying to
keep from being able to show up showing
up and making the sacrifice it needs to
make in order to change the law back to
what it should be
um and uh but it's gonna be difficult i
i make no bones about that it's gonna be
difficult but we're not there yet we've
not run out of options yet and we'll see
how this moves and on omicron and
education teachers are in result in some
revolt in so many places parents are at
odds over closing schools and remote
learning you say we're not going to go
back to closing schools you said that
just moments ago
yet they're closing in some areas what
do you say to those teachers and
principals and parents about school
closings and what can your
administration do to help make up for
learning loss for students first of all
i put in perspective the question you
asked
very
few schools are closing get back 95
are still open
so you all phrase the questions when
people i don't think it's deliberate on
your part but your phrase the question
of anyone watching this on television my
god there must be all those schools must
be closing what are we going to do
95
are still open number one
number two
the idea
that parents don't think it's important
for their children to be in school
and teachers know it as well that's why
we made sure that we had the ability to
provide the funding
through the recovery act through the act
that we the the first act we passed
to be able to make sure schools were
able to be
safe
so we have new ventilation systems
available for them we have the way they
handle they scrub down the laboratories
and
the laboratories kids go to to go to the
bathroom uh cafeterias buses etc that
all that money's there there's billions
of dollars made available it's there
not every school district has used it as
well as it should be used
but
it's there
and so in addition to that there is now
another 10 billion dollars for testing
of students in the schools so i i think
as time goes on
it's much more likely you're going to
see that number go back up from 95
percent back up to 98 99 percent but
right over under does he take more than
three more questions or not open is
always going to get and i'm not being
critical of any of you it's always going
to get front page it's always going to
be the top of the news but let's put it
in perspective
95 as high as 98 of the schools in
america are open
functioning
and capable of doing the job
um
how about uh
uh jan epstein uh bloomberg
mr president thank you um
your top foreign policy advisors have
warned that russia is now ready to
attack ukraine but there's still little
unity among european allies about what a
package of sanctions against moscow
would look like if the us and nato
aren't willing to put troops on the line
to defend ukraine american allies can't
agree on a sanctions package hasn't the
u.s and the west lost nearly all of its
leverage over vladimir putin and
given how ineffective sanctions have
been in deterring putin in the past why
should the threat of new sanctions give
him pause
well because he's never seen
sanctions like the ones i promised will
be imposed if he moves number one
number two we're in a situation where
uh vladimir putin uh is about to uh
we've had very frank discussions uh
vladimir putin and i
and uh
the idea that nato is not going to be
united i don't buy i've spoken to every
major nato leader
we've had the nato russian summit we've
had other the osce has met etc and so i
think what you're going to see
is that
russia will be held accountable if it
invades and it depends on what it does
it's one thing if it's a minor incursion
and then we end up having to fight about
what to do and not do etc but if they
actually do what they're capable of
doing with the force of mass on the
border so the big news just in the last
hour is that the u.s seems ready to send
military aid to ukraine and i'm going to
talk about it on the podcast tomorrow
severe cost and significant harm on
russia and the russian economy
and you know we're going to fortify our
nato allies i told him on the eastern
flank if in fact he does invade
we're going to i've already shipped over
600 million dollars worth of
sophisticated equipment defensive
equipment to the ukrainians the cost of
going into ukraine in terms of physical
loss of life for the russians and
they'll they'll be able to prevail over
time but it's going to be heavy it's
going to be real it's going to be
consequential in addition to that putin
has a you know has
a stark choice uh he either
de-escalation or diplomacy a
confrontation of the consequences look i
think you're going to see
for example
everybody talks about how russia has
control over the
uh the energy supply
that europe absorbs
well guess what that
that that money
that they earned from that makes about
45 of the economy
i don't see that as a one-way street
they go ahead and cut it off
it's like my mother used to say you're
biting your nose off to spite your face
right like they have all these wonderful
choices out there
i spoke with the prime minister of
finland
and uh you know we're talking about uh
concern on the part of finland and
sweden about what russia is doing the
last thing that that russia needs is
finland deciding to change its status
they didn't say they're going to do that
but they're talking about what in fact
is going on and how outrageous russia
has been
we're finding ourselves in a position
where
i believe you'll see that uh there'll be
severe economic consequences for example
anything that involves dollar
denominations if they make a if they
invade they're going to pay they're not
going their banks will not be able to
deal in dollars
so there's a lot going to happen but
here's the thing
my conversation with putin and we've
been um how can we say it
we have no
problem understanding one another
he has no problem understanding me nor
me him did they fall in love though and
the direct the conversations were i
pointed out i said you know
you've uh occupied before other
countries
but the price has been extinct
how long
you can go in and over time have great
loss and economic loss go in and occupy
ukraine
but
how many years
one three five ten
what what is that going to take what
toll does that take
it's real it's consequential
so this is not all just a cake walk
for russia
militarily they have overwhelming
superiority
and on on
as it relates to ukraine
but they'll pay a stiff price
immediately
near term medium term and long term if
they do it wow
um i'm sorry
okay
[Music]
david sanger new york times
thank you mr president i wanted to
follow up on your answer there
about russia and ukraine
when you were in geneva in june
you said to us
about president putin i think the last
thing he wants now is a cold war now
since then of course you've seen him
gather these troops hundred thousand
troops around ukraine your secretary of
state said today he thought he could
invade it at any moment you've seen the
cyber attacks
and you've seen the demand that he have
a sphere of influence in which you would
withdraw
all american troops and nuclear weapons
from what used to be the soviet bloc so
i'm wondering if you still think
that the last thing he wants is a cold
war
and has your view of him changed in the
past few months
and if it has
and he does invade would your posture be
to really move back
to the kind of containment policy that
you saw so often when you were
still in the senate that's a good
question the answer is that um
i think he still does not want any
full-blown war
number one
number two
do i think he'll test the west test the
united states and nato as
as
significantly as he can yes i think he
will
but i think he'll pay a serious and dear
price for it that he doesn't think now
will cost him what it's going to cost
him
and i think he'll regret having done it
now
whether or not i think that
how can i say this
in a public forum
[Music]
i think
that
he
is dealing with
what i believe he thinks is the most
tragic thing that's happened
to mother russia
in that
the berlin wall came down the empire has
been lost and near abroad is gone etc
the soviet union has been this is
actually a good reflection from biden
but think about what he has
he has eight time zones
a burning tundra that will not freeze
again
naturally
a situation where he has a lot of oil
and gas
but he is trying to find his place in
the world between
china and the west
absolutely i'm not so sure
that he has
uh
david i'm not so sure he has uh
is certain what he's going to do my
guess is he will move in
that is a more accurate foreign policy
assessment taking into consideration
history than trump ever gave during his
entire presidency one is
ukraine will never be part of nato
and two
that
nato or the there will not be strategic
weapons stationed in
ukraine
we can work out something on the second
piece
pretending what he does along the
russian line as well the russian border
in the european area of russia
on the first piece
we have a number of treaties
internationally and in europe that
suggests that you get to choose who you
want to be with
but the likelihood that ukraine is going
to join nato in the near term is not
very likely
based on
much more work they have to do in terms
of democracy and a few other things
going on there
and whether or not the major allies in
the west would vote to bring ukraine in
right now
so there's room to work if he wants to
do that but i think as usual he's going
to
well i probably shouldn't go any further
but i think it will hurt him badly
it sounds like you're
offering
some way out here some off ramp and it
sounds like what it is is
at least an informal assurance that nato
is not going to uh take in ukraine
any time in the next few decades and it
sounds like you're saying we would never
put nuclear weapons there he also wants
us to move all of our nuclear weapons
out of europe and not have
troops rotating through the old soviet
block do you think there's space for the
there no
no there's not space for that we won't
permanently station but the idea we're
not going to we're going to actually
increase true presence in poland and
romania so
if in fact he moves because we have a
sacred obligation in article 5 to defend
those countries they are part of nato we
don't have that obligation relative to
ukraine although we have great concern
about what happens in ukraine
thank you
um
maureen
usa today
thank you mr president i want to follow
up on your comment on buildback better
and also ask you a question about the
pandemic
you said that you're confident you can
pass big chunks of build back better
this year does that wording mean that
you are thinking about you're looking at
breaking the package up into
individual portions and uh then on the
pandemic now that the supreme court has
blocked the vaccination or test rule for
larger businesses are you can
reconsidering whether to require
vaccines for domestic flights as a way
to boost vaccination rates
uh no look uh first of all uh
on the
last part of the question
the supreme court decision i think was a
mistake but you still see
thousands and thousands of people who
work for major corporations having to be
tested as a consequence of the decision
made by the corporation not by the
standard i said that that is there i
think you'll see that increase not
decrease number one
what was the first part of your question
uh on your your comment that you made
that you're confident that major chunks
of build-back better can pass are you
breaking it up does that yes well uh
it's clear to me that uh
um that we're gonna have to uh probably
uh break it up
um i think that we can i've been talking
to
a number of my colleagues on the hill i
think it's clear that
we would be able to get support for
the four of the 500 plus billion dollars
for
energy and the environmental issues that
are there
on number one
number two uh
i know that
the two people who've opposed on the
democratic side at least
um
support a number of things that are in
there for example joe manchin strongly
supports early education three year and
four years of age strongly supports that
um there is strong support for
i think uh a number of uh
the way in which to pay for these
uh uh pay for this proposal
so i think there is i'm not gonna how
about that i'm not gonna negotiate
against myself as to what should and
shouldn't be in it but i think we can
break the package up get as much as we
can now and come back and fight for the
rest later
ken the wall street journal number four
since i said three or more uh thank you
mr president i wanted to ask you about
the economy as you said earlier
americans are feeling the squeeze of
inflation uh oil prices have been at
about a seven year high recently
how long should americans expect to face
higher prices when they're at the
grocery store when they're at the gas
pump is this something that they're
going to see into the summer into next
fall
and and separately you know you talk
about the importance of the fed but
isn't that an acknowledgement that
you're limited in what you can do if you
if if you're relying on the fed to make
decisions and you're unable to get a
build back better proposal through
aren't you simply limited in what you
can do to deal with inflation
well very strongly
as you know ken um
the inflation has everything to do with
the supply chain
and uh
i think what you're seeing is that
we've been able to make
progress on speeding up
the access to
materials uh for for example
one-third
of the call of the
increase in cost of living is the cost
of automobiles
the reason automobiles have skyrocketed
in price is because of lack of computer
chips
so we have the capacity and we're going
to do everything in our power to do it
to become self-reliant on the computer
chips that we need in order to be able
to produce more automobiles
that's underway we've already passed
within the context of another bill uh
money for that in the uh
in the house of representatives before
the house representatives now but i
think there's a way we can move to
if we can move to get for example that
one thing done it can make a big
difference in terms of the cost of the
total cost of
of living now with regard to um
the whole issue of energy prices um
that gets a little more complicated but
you saw what happened when i was able to
convince everyone from including china
india a number of other countries to
agree with us to go into their version
of the of this of their petroleum
reserve to release more into the market
so that that brought down the price
about 12 15 cents a gallon some places
some places more
there's going to be a there's going to
be a reckoning along the line here as to
whether or not we're going to continue
to see oil prices continue to go up
in ways that are going up now
relative to what is going to what impact
that's going to have on the producers
and so
um it's going to be hard i think that's
the place where most middle class people
work class people get hit the most they
pull up to a pump and all of a sudden
instead of paying
two dollars and forty cents a gallon
they're paying five dollars a gallon
that's going to be really difficult but
so we're going to continue to work on
trying to increase oil supplies that are
available and i think there's ways in
which we can be of some value added in
terms of the price of gas natural gas
and the like to take the burden off the
european countries that
are now totally dependent on on russia
but it's going to be hard it's going to
be very hard but i think that we have to
deal with for example like i said you
have a circumstance where
people are paying more for a pound of
hamburger meat than they ever paid well
one of the reasons for that is you don't
have that many folks out there that are
the ones that are got the big four
controlling them all
and so you're going to see more and more
we're going to move on this competition
piece to allow more and more smaller
operations to come in and be able to
engage in
providing buying and providing the
access to much cheaper
meat
than
than exists now
but it's going to be a hall now and as
you i assume the reason you said if i
can't get bill back better it relates to
what those uh 17 nobel laureate
economists said that if in fact we could
pass it it would actually
lower the impact on inflation reduce
inflation over time etc
so there's a lot we have to do it's not
going to be easy but i think we can get
it done but it's going to be painful for
a lot of people in the meantime that's
why the single best way the single best
way to take the burden off middle class
and work class folks is to pass the
buildback better piece that are things
that they're paying a lot of money for
now
if you get to trade off higher gases
you're putting up with higher price of
hamburgers and
gas
versus whether or not you're going to
have to you're going to be able to pay
for
uh education and or
child care it's alike i think most
people would make the trade their bottom
line would be better in middle class
households but it's going to be hard and
that's going to take a lot of work
oh sir
you mentioned china do you think the
time has come
to begin lifting some of the tariffs
china on chinese imports or is there a
need for china to to
make due on some of its commitments in
the phase one agreement some business
groups would like you to begin raising
uh lifting up those uh tariffs on
children well i know that and that's
true shouldn't biden insult the chinese
now like trump the answer is uncertain
it's uncertain i'd like to be able to be
in a position where i can say they're
meeting the commitments or more their
commitments and be able to lift some of
it but we're not there yet
um
nancy uh
cbs wow we're still going thank you so
much mr president this afternoon the
senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
said that the midterm elections are
going to be
a report card on your progress on
inflation border security and standing
up to russia do you think that that's a
fair way to look at it and if so how do
you think that reports the voters
i think report cards could look pretty
good if that's where we're at but look
the idea that uh
mitch has been very clear
he's doing anything to prevent biden
from being a success i i get on with
mitch i actually like mitch mcconnell oh
we like one another but he has one
straightforward
objective
make sure that there's nothing i do
that makes me look good
in the mind in his mind with the public
at large and that's okay i'm a big boy
i've been here before
but the fact is that i think that
the
i'm happy to debate
and have a referendum on how i handle
the economy
whether or not i've
made progress on went up look again
how can i i'm taking too long answering
your questions i apologize
no no need to apologize i think that
the fundamental question is
what's mitch for
mitch's primary and sole goal is to
ensure i'm humiliated as president we
get along great when you put that aside
what's he for
dealing with
russia
that's different than i'm proposing that
many of his republican friends or his
colleagues are supporting as well what's
he for
on these things what are they for
so everything's a choice
a choice
i think
look i've laid out a proposal
on immigration that if we
the audio feedback is a disaster it's
right now but we're not there
and our incredible oh these people don't
know what the hell they're doing
so
i mean it's it's just
it's going to take time and again i go
back to
i go back to governor sununu's quote
how long i mean a rhetorical question i
don't i know this is not fair to ask
press the question i'm not asking you
but think about
did you ever think
that one man out of office
could intimidate an entire party
where they're unwilling
to take any vote
contrary to what he thinks should be
taken
for fear of being defeated in the
primary
i've had five republican senators
talk to me
bump into me quote unquote
or sit with me
who told me that they agree with
whatever i'm talking about for them to
do right but joe
if i do it
i'm going to defeat it in a primary
i got to break that
it's got to change
and i doubt you're all i'm not sounds
like i'm being solicitous you're all
bright as hell well-informed
more informed than any group of people
in america
but did any of you think
that you get to a point
where not a single
republican
would diverge on a major issue
not one
anyway
those five republican senators are sure
no you're kidding me
i
i maintained confidentiality
and i'm sure you've spoken to some
uh on voting rights sir at your first
press conference ten months ago i asked
you if there was anything you could do
beyond legislation to protect voting
rights and at that time you said yes but
i'm not going to lay out a strategy
before you and the world now
now that legislation appears to be
hopelessly stalled
can you now lay out your strategy to
protect voting rights
well i'm not prepared to do that
in detail in terms of the executive
orders i may be able to engage in and
other things i can do but one of the
things we have done
we have we have significantly beefed up
a number of enforcers in the justice
department
who are there to challenge
the these these unconstitutional efforts
in our view unconstitutional efforts on
the part of the republicans to stack the
election and subvert the outcomes
we have uh began to organize in ways
that we didn't before
the communities beyond the civil rights
community to make the case to the rest
of the american people what's about to
happen what will happen if in fact these
things move forward
if i had talked to you not you i'm using
you in a ptosis if i've talked to the
public
about
the whole idea of subversion of
elections by deciding who the electors
are after the fact i think people would
have looked at me like whoa i mean i
caught talk constitutional law for 20
years a three-credit course in
separation of powers and uh
on saturday morning when i was a senator
and uh
i i never thought we'd get into a place
where
um
where we were talking about being able
actually
what they tried to do this last time out
send different electors
to the
legislative bodies
to represent who won the election
saying that i didn't win but
republican candidate won
um i doubt if anybody thought that would
ever happen
in america in the 21st century but it's
happening
and so i think i guess what i'm saying
is uh nancy is that i think that
there are a number of things we can do
but i also think we will be able to get
significant pieces of the legislation if
we don't get it all now
to build to get it so that we get
biden should really comment on trump's
latest proposal and we will ban men and
you touted the number of americans who
are now fully vaccinated with two shots
but even some of your own medical
advisors say that people aren't fully
protected unless they have that third
shot a booster why hasn't this white
house changed the definition of fully
vaccinated to include that third booster
shot is it because the
numbers of fully vaccinated americans
would suddenly look a lot less no
this has been this has become clear and
clearer and every time i speak of it i
say
if you've been vaccinated get your
booster shot
everybody get the booster shot it's the
ability the optimum protection you can
have
you're protected very well with two
shots if it's the pfizer anyway you're
protected but you are better protected
with the booster shot right
the definition right now
i'm following what the
the answer is yes get the booster shot
it's all part of the same thing
oh man okay uh
alex alford reuters
thank you mr president um i wanted to
follow up briefly on a question asked by
uh bloomberg you said that russia would
be held accountable if it invades and it
depends on what it does it's one thing
if it's a minor incursion and we end up
having to fight about what to do and
what not to do
are you saying that a minor incursion by
russia into ukrainian territory would
not lead to the sanctions that you have
threatened or are you effectively giving
putin permission to make a small
incursion into the country
good question
um
so i did charlotte didn't it
the most important thing to do
big nations can't bluff
number one
number two
the idea
that we would do anything to split nato
which would be of have a profound impact
on one of
i think prominent impact on one of
putin's objectives is to weaken nato
would be a big mistake
so the question is
if it's a something significantly short
of
a significant invasion or not even
significant just major military forces
coming across for example
uh
it's one thing to determine that if they
continue
to
to use cyber efforts well we can respond
the same way with cyber
they have fsb people in ukraine now
trying to undermine
the solidarity within ukraine about
russia and to try to promote russian
interest
but it's very important that uh
that we keep
everyone in nato on the same page
and that's what i'm spending a lot of
time doing and there are differences
there are differences
in nato as to what countries are willing
to do
depending on what happens the degree to
which they're able to go and i want to
be clear with you
the
serious imposition of sanctions relative
to dollar transactions and other things
are things that are going to have a
negative impact on the united states
as well as a negative impact on the
economies of europe as well a
devastating impact on russia
and so i got to make sure everybody's on
the same page
as we move along
i think we will if there's something
that is that where there's russian
forces crossing the border killing
ukrainian fighters etc i think that
changes everything
but it depends on what he does is
exactly what extent we're going to be
able to get total unity on the russia on
the
nato front if i may ask a quick one on
iran i just wanted to get your sense of
whether the vienna talks are making any
progress if you still think it's
possible to reach a deal for both sides
to resume compliance with the iran
nuclear deal or if it's time to give up
on that thank you
i'll do it in reverse it's not time to
give up there is some progress being
made
the p5 plus one is on the same page
but it remains to be seen
um
okay
kristen
nbc
um very quickly on russia um i do have a
number of domestic policy issues but on
on russia very quickly it seemed like
you said that you have assessed you feel
as though he will move in has this
administration have you determined
whether president putin plans to
invade or move into ukraine as you said
look um
the only thing i'm
confident of
is that decision is totally solely
completely a putting decision
nobody else is going to make that
decision no one else is going to impact
that decision he's making that decision
and
i suspect
it matters
which side of the bet he gets up on in
the morning
as to exactly what he's going to do
and i think it is
not irrational if you wanted to to talk
about
dealing with strategic doctrine and
dealing with
force structures in europe and in in
the european parts of russia
but
i don't know whether he's decided he
wants to do that or not
so far in the three meetings we've had
osce anyway
have have not produced anything because
the impression i get
from my secretary of state my national
security advisor and my other senior
officials that are doing these meetings
is that
there's a question of whether the people
they're talking to know
what he is going to do so the answer is
uh but based on
a number of criteria as to what he could
do for example
for him to move
in and
occupy the whole country particularly
from the north from belarus it's uh he's
going to have to wait a little bit until
the ground's frozen so he can cough
to move in a direction where
he wants to talk about what's going we
we have we're continuing to provide
for defense capacities to the to the
ukrainians
we're talking about what's going on
in both the uh the baltic and the black
sea etc there's a whole range of things
that i'm sure
he's trying to calculate how quickly he
can do what he wants to do and what does
he want to do
but i he's not
he's an informed individual
and i'm sure i'm not sure i believe
he's calculating
what the immediate
the short-term
and the near-term and the long-term
consequences of russia will be
and i don't think he's made up his mind
yet i want to ask you about your
domestic agenda you've gotten a lot of
questions about voting rights
mr president but i want to ask you about
black voters one of your most loyal
constituencies
i was in congressman clyburn's district
yesterday in south carolina you opened
this news conference talking about him i
spoke to a number of black voters who
fought to get you elected and now they
feel as though you're not fighting hard
enough for them and their priorities and
they told me they see this push on
voting rights more as a last-minute pr
push than it is a legitimate effort to
get legislation passed so what do you
say to these black voters who say that
you do not have their backs as you
promised on the campaign trail i've had
their back i've had their back my entire
career i've never not had their back
and i started on the voting rights
issues long long ago that's what got me
involved in politics in the first place
and uh i think part of the problem is
look there's there's significant
disagreement
in every community
on whether or not the timing of
assertions made by
people has been in the most timely way
so i'm sure that there are those who are
saying that why didn't biden
push
john lewis bill
as hard as he pushed at the last month
why didn't he push it six months ago as
hard as he did now
um
the fact is that
there is um
there's a timing
that is not of one's own choice it's so
what dictated by events that are
happening in country and around the
world as to what the focus is
but part of the problem is as well
i have not been
out in the community nearly enough
i've been here an awful lot
i find myself in a situation where
i don't get a chance to look people in
the eye
because of both covet and
things that are happening in washington
to be able to go out and do the things
that i've always been able to do pretty
well
connect with people let them take a
measure of my sincerity let them take a
measure of who i am
for example i mean as i pointed out in
south carolina
you know
last time when i was chairman of
judiciary committee i got the voting
rights act extended for 25 years and i
got strong thurman to vote for it
that's what i've been doing my whole
career
and so the idea that i that
that i didn't either anticipate
or because
i didn't speak to it
as fervently
as they want me to earlier
in the meantime i was spending a lot of
time
spent hours and hours and hours
talking with my colleagues on the
democratic side trying to get them to
agree that if in fact
this occurred if this push continued
that they would be there for john lewis
and anyway
so um
but i think that's that's a problem
this was not the best answer by far from
today
as much as i should have yet
you find that uh when you deal with
members of the black caucus and others
in the united states congress i still
have very close working relationships so
it's like every community i'm sure that
there are
those in the community and
i'm a big labor guy i'm sure there's
people in labor saying why i haven't
able to do a b c or d
so it's just going to take a little bit
of time
you put vice president harris in charge
of voting rights are you satisfied with
her work
on this issue very sad and can you
guarantee do you commit that she will be
your running mate in 2024 provided that
you run again
yes and yes
okay whoa
expand
find me do you care to expand
no there's no need to i mean i asked the
question she's gonna be my running mate
number one and number two i did put her
in charge i think she's doing a good job
let me ask you
big picture particularly when you think
about voting right how many questions
does kristen welker get your own party
around voting rights unity was one of
your key campaign promises
in fact in your inaugural address you
said your whole soul was in bringing
america together uniting our people
people heard the speech that you gave on
voting rights in georgia recently in
which you described those who are
opposed to you to george wallace and
jefferson davis and some people took
exception to that what do you say to
those who are offended by your speech
and is this country more unified than it
was when you first took office number
one
anybody who listened to the speech
i did not say
that they were going to be george
wallace or
bull connor
i said we're going to have a decision in
history
that is going to be marked just like it
was then
you either voted on the side that didn't
make you george wallace or didn't make
you bull connor but if you did not vote
for the voting rights act back then you
were voting with those who agreed with
connor
those who agreed with
with and and so
and i i think mitch did a real good job
of making it sound like i was attacking
them if you notice i haven't attacked
anybody publicly
any senator any any any any kind of
trump publicly
and my disagreements with them have been
made to them
communicate to them privately or in
person with them
my desire still is look
i
underestimated one very important thing
i never thought
that
the republicans like for example i said
they got very upset i said there's 16
members
of the present united states senate
who voted
to extend the voting rights act
now they got very offended by that that
wasn't an accusation just stating the
fact
what has changed
what happened
what happened
why is not a single republican
not one
that's not the republican party so
that's not an attack
is the country more unified than when
you first took office
uh the answer is
based on some of the stuff we've got
done i'd say yes but it's not nearly
unified as it should be look
i still contend
and i know you'll have a right to judge
me by this i still contend
that
unless you can reach consensus in a
democracy
you cannot sustain the democracy
and so this is a real test
whether or not
my uh my my uh
my counterpart in china is right or not
when he says
autocracies are the only thing that are
going to prevail because democracies
take too long to make decisions and
countries are too divided
i believe we're going through one of
those inflection points
in history
that occurs every several generations or
even more than that even more time than
that
where things are changing
almost regardless of any particular
policy
the world's changing
in big ways
we're going to see if you've heard me
say this before we're going to see more
change
in the next 10 years we've saw in the
last 50 years
because of technology
because of fundamental alterations in
alliances that are occurring not because
of any one individual just because of
the nature of things
and so i think you're going to see
an awful lot of transition and the
question is can we keep up with it can
we maintain the democratic institutions
that we have not just here but around
the world
to be able to generate democratic
consensus of how to proceed it's going
to be hard
it's going to be hard
the other side half of them want to end
democracy as we know it and have the
loser be in power so that will be tough
to find agreement with
[Applause]
thank them sir that was peter ducey
screaming there were deep questions
among americans about the consequences
of government from the messy rollout of
5g this week to the afghanistan
withdrawal to testing on covid what have
you done to restore americans faith in
the competence of government and are you
satisfied by
the view
of the competence of your government
look
let's take afghanistan i know you all
would like to focus on that which is
legitimate
we were spending
a trillion dollars a week
i mean a billion dollars a week in
afghanistan for 20 years
raise your hand if you think
anyone was going to be able to
unify
right afghanistan exactly under one
single government we just needed three
more years guys graveyard of empires for
a solid reason
it is not susceptible to unity
number one so
the question was
do i continue
to spend
that much money per week
in the state of afghanistan right
knowing that
the idea that being able to succeed
other than sending more body bags back
home is highly highly unusual
my dad used to have an expression
he said son if everything is equally
important to you nothing's important to
you
there is no way
to get out of afghanistan after 20 years
easily correct not possible no matter
when you did it
and i make no apologies for what i did i
have a great concern for the women and
men
who were blown up
on the line at the airport
by a terrorist attack against them
but
the military will acknowledge and i
think you will who know a lot about
foreign policy
that had we stayed
and i had not pulled those troops out we
would be asked to put somewhere between
20 and 50 000 more troops back in
because the only reason more americans
weren't being killed than others is
because the last president signed an
agreement to get out by may the first
and so everything was copacetic
had we not gotten out
and the acknowledgement is we'd be
putting a lot more forces in
now am i do i feel badly what's
happening to
we as a consequence of the incompetence
of the taliban
yes i do
but i feel badly also about the fistulas
that are taking place in the eastern
congo
i feel badly about a whole range of
things around the world
that we can't solve every problem
and so
i don't view that as a competence issue
the issue of whether or not there's
competence in terms of whether or not
we're dealing with 5g or not
we don't deal with 5g
the fact is that you had two enterprises
two private enterprises
that had one promoting 5g
and the other one are airlines
they're private enterprises they have
government regulation admittedly
and so what i've done
is
pushed as hard as i can
to have
5g folks hold up
and abide by what was being requested by
the airlines until they could more
modernize over the years right so that a
5g would not interfere with the
potential of the landing so any tower
any 5g tower within a certain number of
miles from the airport
should not be operative
and that's and so i understand but
anything that happens that's
consequential
is viewed as the government's
responsibility i get that guys he was
asked about 5g for people thinking he's
bringing this up out of nowhere he was
asked about 5g uh um covet and all the
things that uh
that go along with that yeah i am
satisfied i think we've done it
remarkably well
you know the idea that uh
on testing we've done we should have
done it quicker but we've done
remarkable since then what we have is we
have more testing going on than anywhere
in the world and we're going to continue
to increase that
did we have it at the moment exactly
when we should have
i just want to admit something to you
guys i've had 5g forever now
and when it says i'm on 5g
it seems insanely slow like there's like
almost a delay before the page loads i
don't know maybe my expectations are off
it seems to be working more slowly when
on 5g very weird anecdotal
well guess what
they didn't have the machinery to be
able to do it
so i physically went
to michigan
stood there in a factory with the head
of the uh of uh um astrazeneca and said
we'll provide the machinery for you this
is what we'll do we'll help you do it so
you can produce this vaccine more
rapidly
i think that's pretty hands-on stuff
we also said right now when people the
hospitalizations
are are are running hospitals and you
have docs and nurses out because of
coven they have covet
we put thousands of people back in in
those hospitals look at all the marine
all the military personnel we have there
first responders
nobody is ever organized nobody has ever
organized
a strategic operation to get as many
shots and arms by opening clinics and
keeping and being able to get so many
people vaccinated what i'm doing now is
not just getting significant amounts of
vaccines to the rest of the world but
they now need the mechanical way is how
they get shots in arms
so we're providing them to know how to
do that now should everybody in america
know that no i don't necessarily know
that they're just trying to figure out
how to put three squares on the table
and stay safe
but so
i i i do think the place where i was a
little disappointed i wish we could have
written it differently
is when we did the legislation to
provide the funding for covet and the
money we provided for the states to be
able to deal with keeping schools open
some of them didn't do a very good job
some are still holding the money
i don't have the authority to do
anything about that
i think that's not particularly
competent there's things that could and
should have been done they could have
moved faster
so
i uh um
i understand the frustration
you know i remember
uh
um
i think it was uh i forget which cabinet
member is saying to barack obama where
something was going on
and he said well you're going to be sure
mr president of the millions of
employees you have out there somebody's
screwing up right now
somebody's screwing up
so
you know it's just uh but i think you
have to look at things that we used to
look at on balance
what is the trajectory of the country is
it moving in the right direction now
i don't know how we can say it's not i
understand the overwhelming frustration
fear and concern
with regard to inflation
and covet i get it
but the idea if i told you
when we started i'll tell you what i'm
going to do first year i'm going to
create over 600 or 6 million jobs
i'm going to get unemployment down to
3.9 percent i'm going to generate and i
named it all you look at me like you're
nuts
maybe i'm wrong
president at least in our recent memory
with as much washington experience as
you entered this office with but yet
after we sit here for more than an hour
i'm not sure i've heard you say if you
would do anything differently in the
second year of your term do you plan to
do anything differently the thing you
have to do satisfied with your team here
at the white house i'm satisfied with
the team there's three things i'm going
to do differently now that i will now
that i've gotten the critical crises out
of the way in the sense of that moving
knowing exactly where we're going
number one
i'm going out of this place more often
i'm going to go out and talk to the
public
i'm going to do public fora
i'm going to interface with them i'm
going to make the cases what we've
already done
why it's important and what we'll do if
what will happen if they support what
else i want to do number two
i'm bringing in more and more now that i
have time i mean literally like you it's
i'm not complaining it's you know 12 14
hours a day no complaints i really mean
it sincerely but now that certain of the
big chunks have been put in place and we
know the direction i'm also going to be
out there seeking the more advice of
experts outside from academia to
editorial writers to think tanks and i'm
bringing them in
just like i did early on bringing in uh
presidential historians to get their
perspective on what we should be doing
seeking more input more information more
constructive criticism about what i
should and shouldn't be doing
and the third thing i'm going to be
doing a lot more of is being in a
situation where i'm able to
bring i'm going to be deeply involved in
the off these off your elections
we're going to be raising a lot of money
we're going to be out there making sure
that we're helping all those candidates
and score some already asked me it will
be interesting to see how much of a help
biden is for democrats running in 22.
language as to what it is we've done
what we want to do and why we think it's
important
how many more hours am i doing this i'm
happy to stick around
look at peter ducey out of his mind you
always ask me the nicest questions
i know you do all right none of them
make a lot of sense to me but i
well let's let's try our way come on new
year oh man why are you trying so hard
in your first year to pull the country
so far to the left
well what a juice i don't know what you
can say clinical due for the left if in
fact we're talking about
making sure that we had the money for
covert making sure oh god what a clown
together the bipartisan infrastructure
making sure we're able to provide for
okay tomorrow fox reporter asks maybe
the dumbest question in the history of
journalism they have to continue to work
hard i don't know how that is pointed to
the left if you may recall
i uh you guys have been trying to
convince me that uh i am uh
um
bernie sanders i'm not i like him but
i'm not bernie sanders i'm not a
socialist what a question i'm a
mainstream democrat and i have been and
mainstream democrats have overwhelmed if
you notice
the
biden's not that progressive the
republican democrats
supported me in the senate on virtually
everything i've asked
yes sir
a moment ago you were asked whether or
not you believed that we would have free
and fair elections in 2022 with some of
these state legislatures when it reforms
their voting protocols
you said that it depends
do you
do you think that
they would is there a ladder in the
middle of the room
oh yeah i think an easy community be
illegitimate imagine
imagine if in fact trump has succeeded
in convincing pence to
not count the votes
imagine if
in regards to
2022 so 2052 i mean
imagine if those uh attempts to say that
uh
the count was not legit
you have to recount it and we're not
going to count we're going to discard
the following votes i mean sure
it i'm not saying it's going to be legit
it's the increase
in the prospect of being illegitimate is
a direct proportion of us not being able
to get
these reforms passed but i don't think
you're going to see you're not going to
see me and i don't think you're going to
see the democratic party give up on can
go coming back at assuming that the
attempt fails today and then one more
sir um
you know you talk you campaigned and you
ran on a return to civility and i know
that you dispute the characterization
that you called folks who would oppose
those voting bills um as being bull
connor or george wallace but you said
that they would be sort of in the same
camp no i didn't say that look what i
said go back and read what i said
and tell me
if you think i called
anyone who voted on the side of the
position taken by bull connor that they
were bull connor
and that is an interesting reading of
english you you i assume you got into in
the journals because you like to write
oh my god so did you expect that that
would work would you say yes mr
president i like to write
um no here's the thing there's certain
things that are so consequential you
have to speak from your heart as well as
your head
i was speaking out
forcefully on what i think to be at
stake
that's what it is and by the way
no one
no one forgets who was on the side of
king or verse on or bull connor
no one not done that the history books
will note it and when i was making the
case don't think this is a freebie whoa
you don't get to vote this way and then
somehow it goes away this will be stick
with you the rest of your career and
long after you're gone
and mr president
i'm more on your ukraine pizza
okay
whoa whoa hang on guys it's like being a
kindergarten teacher 20 minutes i'll
keep going but i'm what i'm gonna go let
me get let me get something straight
here
how long are you guys ready to go you
want to go for another hour two
[Laughter]
oh man
okay
i'm gonna go i tell you what folks
uh
i'm gonna go another 20 minutes to a
quarter of okay yes sir wow
thank you
i can't hear a word
i want to thank my communication staff
for the great help here
well uh president biden on the
coronavirus uh we're uh tragically
approaching nearly 1 million
and i'd like to ask you um
during your three and a half hour
virtual summit in november with the
chinese president you didn't press for
transparency and also whether that has
anything to do with your son's
involvement in an investment firm
controlled by chinese state entities
uh oh
we did i did raise the question of
transparency i spent a lot of time with
him
and he uh the fact is that they're just
not they're just not being transparent
transparency on the crotavirus origins
yes
and
you did during the virtual summit is
there a reason your press staff was
unaware of that
and what did you say to the chinese
president and they weren't with me the
entire time look
i
made it clear that i thought that china
had an obligation to be more forthcoming
on exactly what to say got a package at
the door the virus was and where it came
from
yes
mr president i would like to ask you
about foreign policy
one of the first priority uh that you
declared when you came to office was to
end the war in yemen the catastrophic
war in yemen
you appointed a special envoy today one
of your allies united arab emirates is
asking your administration
to put back the houthi rebels or
militias back on the terror list are you
going to do that and how are you going
to end the war in yemen sir
the answer is
it's under consideration and
ending the war in yemen takes the two
parties to be involved to do it
and it's going to be very difficult
yes
thank you very much for this honor james
rosen with newsmax i'd like to um i'd
like to raise a delicate
subject
but with utmost respect for your life
accomplishments and the high office you
hold
a
poll released this morning
by politico morning consult
found
49
of registered voters
disagreeing with the statement
joe biden is mentally fit
not even a majority of democrats who
responded
uh strongly affirmed that statement
i'll let you all make the judgment
wasn't correct well so the question i
have for you sir if you'd let me finish
is why do you suppose
such large segments of the american
electorate
have come to harbor
such profound concerns
about your cognitive fitness thank you
i have no idea
yes sir
uh thanks mr president i appreciate it
um i i wanted to sort of address uh or
ask about attention that's been in this
in this press conference on unifying the
country because you campaigned on two
things one of them is being able to
accomplish big things and the other is
the ability to unify the country and
even today you've talked about sort of a
different posture with republicans and i
i wonder if if you still think it's
possible to do both of those things
we have to
we have to let me
as long as i hold public office i'm
going to continue to attempt to do both
things one more follow-up um
around this time last year when you were
campaigning in georgia i think one of
the things you told people was the power
is literally in your hands you know if
if voters give democrats the house and
the senate and and the presidency that
all these big things can get
accomplished and you know we've seen
stalemate we've seen things being
stymied um
why should folks believe you this time
around can you think of any other
president's done as much in one year
name one for me
i'm asking you
i'm serious you guys talk about how
nothing's happened
i don't think there's been much
on any incoming president's plate that's
been a bigger menu than the plate i had
given to me i'm not complaining do that
running in
and the fact of the matter is we got an
awful lot done not a joke an awful lot
done
and there's more to get done but look
let's let me ask a rhetorical question
no i will anyway
thank you oh that's genius yes
i wanted to hear it
be careful don't get hurt no no i'm i'm
gonna take care
uh mr president thank you sebastian
smith from afp another question on
ukraine
uh ukraine borders for nato member
countries
how concerned are you are you concerned
uh that
oh i missed the newsmax question oh no
really go in there
that it could suck in
nato countries that are on the border
and you end up with an actual
nato-russia confrontation of some kind
and secondly
are you entertaining the thought of a
summit with
vladimir putin as a way to perhaps try
and put this whole thing to bed address
their concerns and negotiate a way out
of this the last part the last question
yes when we talked about whether or not
we faked the three meetings we talked
about
and we talked about we would go from
there
if there was reason to to go to a summit
we talked about a summit as being before
the ukraine
item came up in terms of strategic
doctrine and what the strategic
relationship would be so i still think
that is a possibility number one number
two i am very concerned
i'm very concerned that this could end
up being
look
the only war that's worse than one
that's intended is one that's unintended
and what i'm concerned about
is this could get out of hand
very easily get out of hand because of
what you said the borders of the of
ukraine and what russia may or may not
do
i am hoping that vladimir putin
understands that he is
short of a full-blown nuclear war he's
not in a very good position to dominate
the world
and so i don't think he thinks that
but it is a concern
and that's why we have to be very
careful about how we move forward and
make it clear to him that there are
there are prices to pay
that could in fact cost his country an
awful lot
but i of course you have to be concerned
when you have you know
a nuclear power
invade this if he invades
it hasn't happened since world war ii
this is the most consequential thing
that's happened
in the world in terms of war and peace
since world war ii i think the oath
keepers are running sound here yes
nearly two years have passed since the
beginning of the global coronavirus
outbreak and you again today acknowledge
that americans are frustrated and
they're tired based on your
conversations with your health advisors
what type of restrictions do you imagine
being on americans this time next year
and what does the new normal look like
for social gatherings and travel to you
well the answer is
i hope the new normal will be that we
don't have still have 30 some million
people not vaccinated i hope the new
normal is people have seen and what
their own interest is and have taken
advantage of the of what we have
available to us number two
with the pill that is a problem that
appears to be as
efficacious as it seems to be
that they're going to be able to deal
with this virus in a way that after the
fact you have an ability to make sure
you don't get yourself you don't get
very sick
number three
i would hope that what happens is the
rest of the world does what i'm doing
and provides significant amounts of the
vaccine to the rest of the world
because it's not sufficient that we just
have this country not have the virus or
be able to control the virus but that we
can't pull the wall high enough to keep
a new variant out so it requires one of
the things that i want to do and we're
we're contemplating figuring out how to
do not we are contemplating how to get
done and that is how do we move in a
direction where the world itself
is vaccinated it's not enough
just to vaccinate 340 million fully
vaccinate 340 million people in the
united states that's not enough
it's not enough to do a new we have to
do it and we have to do a lot more than
we're doing now and that's why we have
continued to keep the commitment of
providing vaccines and available
cures for the rest of the world as well
if i could sir and i should have said
this before francesca chambers mcclatchy
how do you plan to win back moderates
and independents who cast a ballot for
you in 2020 but polls indicate aren't
happy with the way you're doing your job
now i don't believe the pulse
wow
well watch this go down thank you mr
president it's pretty trumpy to say you
don't believe penny poll that's bad
you've given dozens of speeches this
year urging americans to get vaccinated
you've talked to reluctant republicans
you've said it's people's patriotic duty
there's been very few mentions of the
fact that young children under the age
of five still in the third year of this
pandemic in this country
don't have access to the vaccine can you
speak to frustrated parents a little bit
about why that continues to be the case
because the science hasn't reached the
point where they're convinced that in
fact it is safe so that's what they're
doing now
that's really a bad question for a
president like why isn't the vaccine
approved for kids under five i don't
know i'm not doing the research i'm not
the person in charge 7 and 12. well it
finally they got to the point where they
felt secure in the number of tests they
had done and the test had run that it
was safe so it will come it will come
but i can't i'm not a scientist i can't
tell you when but it is really very
important that we get that that next
piece
one more follow-up on buildback better
when you said it's going to likely be
broken up into chunks you mentioned that
the climate pieces seem to have broad
support you mentioned senator manchin as
a supporter of
early child care you left out the child
tax credit and i wonder if it's fair to
read between the lines and assume that
that is a piece given senator manchin's
opposition to it that the extension of
that is likely one of those components
that may have to wait uh until some time
really big components that i feel
strongly about that i'm not sure i can
get in the package
one is the child care tax credit
the other is
help for
cost of community colleges
they are massive things that i've run on
i care a great deal about and i'm going
to keep coming back at whatever four i
get to be able to try to get chunks or
all of that done yes sir the next man
next to your left
thank you mr president my name is pedro
rojas i'm with univision national news
ah this is actually my first press
conference i love this guy good to meet
you in person we always have long press
conferences awesome
awesome
i got a couple of questions for you
number one uh you said that you want to
convey your message by getting out there
in the country i wonder if you're
planning on traveling also to south
america and other countries and the in
the western hemisphere
given the fact that china has has gained
a lot of influence in the region
and the second question is
what will be your message for residents
in this country that are struggling
every time they go to the gas station
every time they go to the grocery store
and see the prices going high
and the pharmacy i happened to come from
south texas where i saw a lot of a lot
of people struggling financially in the
last few months
and so i think you
i wonder what is the message you want to
spread to them
well i try to express i've asked i tried
to answer that seven different ways
today about how to deal with inflation
um but let me uh answer the first
question
i spent a lot of time in south america
and in latin america when i was vice
president i spent the bulk of my eight
years basically in europe and or
in
latin america i'm in contact with the
leaders of the countries in south
america we're working closely with
making sure that we do everything for
example
with the uh to deal with
helping
the countries in question particularly
those in central america to be able to
help them with their ability to deal
with
the inter
people don't sit around in
guatemala and say i got a great idea
let's sell everything we have give the
money to a to a
a coyote take us across a terribly
dangerous trip up through central
america and up through mexico and drop
us sneakers across the border drop us in
the desert won't that be fun
people leave because they have real
problems and one of the things i've done
when i was a vice president got support
with although i don't have much
republican support anymore is provide
billions of dollars to be able to say to
those countries
why are people leaving and how are you
going to reform your own system
and that's we've worked on a long time
it still needs a lot more work and we're
focusing on that i also
believe i've spent a lot of time talking
about and dealing with policy having to
do with maduro who is a little more than
a dictator right now
and the same thing in chile and afghan
and not the same thing but with chile as
well as argentina so look i made a
speech a while ago when i was vice
president
saying that
if we were smart
we have an opportunity to make the
western hemisphere
a
united not united a democratic
hemisphere
and we were moving in the right
direction
under our in the last administration the
obama biden administration
but so much damage was done
as a consequence of the foreign policy
decisions the last president made
in
latin america central america and south
america
that
we now have when i call for a summit of
the democracies
i call that and a number of nations
showed up for this summit of democracy
what is it that's going to allow us
to generate we've actually had a
reduction in the number of democracies
in the world
and it seems to me there's nothing more
important we used to talk about
when i was a kid in college about
america's backyard it's not america's
backyard
said everything south of the mexican
border is america's front yard
and we're equal people we don't dictate
what happens in any other part of that
of this continent
this is pretty meandering guys i'm not
going to sugarcoat it this is this is
kind of weird and also comparing chile
and argentina to venezuela it's kind of
all over the place
and it's going to take some time
yes send them on the back and then i'll
go to this side okay
thank you mr president
and thank you for holding this press
conference i hope there's more of them
um
anytime you have extra three hours we
can do it
we'll stay for a couple more um
you said you were surprised by
republican obstruction of your agenda
but didn't the gop take exactly the same
tactic
when you were vice president to barack
obama so
why did you think they would treat you
and beautiful then they treated him
right first of all they weren't nearly
as obstructionist as they are now
number one oh that guy follows me i knew
that that's alex nasarian from yahoo
yeah we follow each other
he may have been watching the stream and
got the question from me no i'm kidding
even back in those days lindsey graham
and so
the difference here is
there seems to be a desire
to work with and i didn't say my agenda
i'm saying what are they for what what
is their
agenda they had an agenda
back in the administration
when the eight years we were president
vice president but i don't know what
their agenda is now right what is it
the american public is outraged about
the tax structure we have in america
what are they proposing to do about it
anything
have you heard anything
i mean anything i haven't heard anything
the american public is outraged about
the fact that we're
the uh the the the state of the
environment the vast majority of the
public what have they done to do
anything to ameliorate
the climate change that's occurring
other than to deny it exist so what i'm
saying is the difference between then
and now is not only the announcement
that was made anything to stop barack
obama i get that part
but what eventually happened
we were able to get some things done we
were able to work through some things on
the stuff that was really consequential
in terms of ideologically divisive it
was a real fight
but so
but i don't think there's a time when i
i mean i wonder what would be the
republican platform right now right
they don't have one i don't even know
what to do
what do you think their position on
on human rights
i think their position is on whether or
not uh
we should uh on what we should do about
the cost of prescription drugs
what do you think i mean i i just
i honestly got don't know what they're
for yet i know a lot of these senators
and congressmen and i know they do have
things they want to support
whether there's things i want or not
but you don't hear much about that
and every once in a while when you hear
something where there's a consensus
it's important but a small item and it
doesn't get much coverage at all
where it occurs i'm not mean coverage i
mean there's not much discussion about
it
so i just think it's a different
and i i don't know
that um
no matter how strongly one supports as a
republican and or supports
the president of the former president
united states
i don't know how we can't look at
what happened on
january 6th and think that's
that's a problem
that's a real problem
one one more question uh mr president um
by the way it's a quarter of guys now so
i'm going to do this just let's if you
ask me easy questions i'll give you
quick answers
i think among some democrats that
even if schools do continue to open and
i get that most of them are now open
republicans will
weaponize this narrative
of you and other leading democrats
allowing them to stay closed in the
midterms next year
uh and you know obviously that issue has
a lot of traction with
suburban parents um as i think
i'm confused by the question i'm sorry
well that could school
reopenings or closures become a potent
midterm issue for republicans to win
back the suburbs yeah
oh i think it could be but i hope and
god that they're
that
look
maybe i'm kidding myself
but as time goes on
the voter
who is just trying to figure out as i
said
how to take care of their family put
three squares on the table stay safe be
able to pay their mortgage or their rent
etc
uh
has is becoming
much more informed on
the um
that buzzing you guys here when i've
dealt with that usually when i just like
move something to a different plug it
fixes it players
and some of the
and the political parties
and i think that
they are not going to be as susceptible
to believing
some of the outlandish things that have
been said
and continue to be said
you know
every
every president not necessarily in the
first 12 months but every president
first couple years most every president
excuse me of the last president at least
four of them
have had
polling numbers that are 44
favorable so this idea that but you all
not you all but now it is well binds it
i wish someone would ask him to weigh on
it weigh in on whether crackers should
only be whole wheat flour salt and oil i
would love a question about that i mean
the idea that um
the american public are trying to
sift their way through
what's real and what's and what's fake
and i don't think
as
i've never seen a time
when
the political coverage
the choice of what political coverage
the voter looks to
has as much impact on as what they
believe they go to get reinforced
in their views
whether it's uh msnbc or whether it's
fox or what i mean and one of the things
i find fascinating that's happening and
you all are dealing with it every day
and it will impact on
on how things move
is that
a lot of the speculation and the polling
data shows
that
the um
that the uh cables are
heading
south
they're losing viewership
no well
fox is okay for a while but it's not
gaining and a lot of the rest are
predicted to be
not very much in the in the mix
in the next four to five years i don't
know if that's true or not
but i do know
that we have sort of uh
put everybody in put themselves in
certain alleys
and they've decided that
you know
how many people
who
watch msnbc also watch fox other
politicians trying to find out what's
going on in both places
how many people
again i'm no expert in any of this this
is getting a little painful guys it's
getting a little painful no it's not
what gets covered now
is
necessarily a little bit different
than what gets covered in the past
i've had a couple
i should get into this yeah yeah i
wouldn't go with that
but the nature
not
the nature of the way
things get covered
it's my observation over the years i've
been involved in public life changed
and it's changed because of everything
from a thing called the internet
has changed because of the way in which
uh
we have self-identified
perspectives based on what channel you
turn on
what what what network you look at that
network what what cable you look at
and it's um
it's never quite been like that
anyway
i think he should cut it yeah thank you
very much
for standing for our questions we hope
the public has found it as enlightening
as those of us in the room have i want
to ask you sir about one of the overall
i can still stand it's amazing we
appreciate it we we very much do so uh
the question i wanna ask you guys to
accountability sir uh on one of the top
public concerns of course which is the
coronavirus and the pub the government's
response to it whether it's
confusion over what style of mask to
wear
when to test how to test where to test
uh
you know the the public is confused sir
and you see that in in in the drop off
in the polling on this question why did
you tell jeff that you were satisfied
with your team
why are you not willing to make or
interested in making any changes
either at the cdc or other agencies
given the fact that the messages have
been so confusing well first of all
the message is to the extent they've
been confusing is because the scientists
are learning more and learning more
about what's needed and what's not
needed
and so
the fact is that the one piece that has
gotten a lot of attention is the
the
communications capacity of the cdc
well she came along and said look i'm
not a friend i mean i'm a scientist
and i'm learning
i'm learning how to deal with
stating what is the case that we've
observed
um
but look i think that it's a little bit
like saying
when we went through the whole issue of
how to deal with polio and the polio
shots
what was said in the beginning was oh no
it's changed a little bit we moved this
way that way or when we dealt with
anything else i mean
uh
it's as
this was a brand new
virus
a brand new phenomenon
some of it was deadly
otherwise more communicable this is
this is an unfolding story
it's the nature of the way diseases
spread we're going to learn about it in
a lot of other areas just and not just
covert 19.
and so
i think you know
i look at it this way think about
how astounding it was within the time
frame that it took
to be able to come up with a vaccine
you used to write about that
pretty amazing
how rapidly they came up with a vaccine
that saved hundreds of thousands of
lives
did everything get right no
and by the way the idea whether we is it
just me or is that hum getting worse
thank you mr president i have two really
simple questions
i promise you campaigned on cancelling
ten thousand dollars in student loans do
you still plan to do so and when and
then my second question is now that
you've clarified the bull connor
comments do you plan to reach out to
republicans like mitt romney to talk
about reforming the electoral count act
yes i'm happy to speak out i've i've met
with rip i've talked to mitt on other
occasions and by the way i reached out
to the minority the minority leader as
well
at the time this that he they made a
speech
and so
um
i have no reluctance
to reach out to any republican
and anyone who and i've made it clear
look i've now had the opportunity to
travel
because of
funerals and eulogies i've made and
attendant and congressmen and senators
have come along with me
i don't don't hold me to the number but
somewhere
between 20 and 25 senators and congress
persons have traveled with me
and i find you should get the list of
them and ask what how we i you know set
for the two three four five hours that
we've flown together sit back in the in
that conference table and talk to them
ask them questions they ask me questions
i learn a heck of a lot but as president
you don't quite have that ability to do
that as often as i like the student loan
part
and one of the things that i do think
that has been made clear to me speaking
of polling
is the public doesn't want me to be the
president senator
they want me to be the president and let
senators be senators and so
if i've made i've made many mistakes i'm
sure if i've made a mistake i'm used to
negotiating to get things done and i've
been
in the past relatively successful at it
in the united states senate even as vice
president but i think that role as
president is
is a different rule
folks
it is now uh almost six what about
student loans with all due respect i'm
gonna
see you next conference okay thank you
yo
he literally just did not even address
the student loan piece but after almost
two hours president biden concluding a
really a wide-ranging news conference in
which he wait did he just come
back did you did you walk back into the
room at the last second let's see i'm
gonna see you next conference okay thank
you
and there he goes
okay and there it is over
uh wow a nearly two
hour press conference
from president
joe biden
wow well i'm gonna have to think about
all of it for a long time
i really appreciate everybody who joined
me i appreciate the raid on twitch from
jeff waldorf great to see you jeff
and we will be back
almost before you know it
at the next stream thank you